good morning john good morning alex and  good morning to you  sherry is off today and welcome to  summer which we begin  with the expiration of the excessive  heat warning but don't get the wrong  idea it is still pretty warm out there  now we've had some overnights  with lows in the 90s we're at 88 right  now that is six degrees cooler than  yesterday  wind is going to be a factor today  that's why the national weather service  has gone ahead and issued  fire weather and red flag warnings a  combination of very strong wind  low humidity and very hot temperatures  combining to make real fire danger  meantime so from the upper 80s we're  going to get you into the mid 90s by 8  we think it will be above 100 still by  noon  afternoon high of 109 not a record but  still way above normal and still hanging  around 107. you see the winds picking up  to 15 20 and 25 miles an hour throughout  the day